it's kind of like you're selling
yourself like it's like your online
portfolio like your representation of
yourself like so you're sharing your
good parts like you're showing yourself
looking your best for other people
that's basically it though yeah no for
for attention for other people to view
it
so no but we were talking about the
other day
where like instagram and everything like
that it's actually a social currency now
like even when you go out and stuff
like the more followers you have the
more like you can do the easier to get
into things yeah
element but as a girl if your
instagram's open and it's not private
like you want the attention if you're
not doing if you're not if you're not
trying to like sell something towards a
business or like do something i feel
like it's for attention
a little bit i think it's a great way to
have an instagram even if it's open or
private i mean when it's open of course
i think you have way more
possibilities you know to create a
business to share and to create more
following definitely
uh some i don't think is like the main
reason is like to like to create an
instagram is to she i'm sorry to cheat
no [ __ ]
but
i mean
uh i think you can [ __ ] [ __ ]
in portuguese guys don't judge me um
[ __ ] cheat cheat thank you
cheat uh you can cheat anywhere you know
i mean there was cheating before
instagram before social media before
internet i i think even my parents i
don't know if they cheat but you know
even that happened before but without
internet without you know uh smartphones
it was like a nokia the snake game you
know that's it
but i think what he was trying to say i
i agree with you that's what i said as
well but i think it gives you an outlet
to do it easier yeah we have
i think all of us have experienced
someone being a relationship posting it
and then they swipe up on your story
yeah you're like
what
well i think it just gives you that
interesting stat
one and three affairs that cause a
divorce are from social media exactly
yeah
yeah one and three
there we go so i feel like social media
has made it harder for relationships to
work because you're as you're as a guy
you're seeing all these beautiful girls
on your timeline
constantly you're gonna be tempted
you're like oh there's more beautiful
girls out there you're good seeing all
these girls so you're so it's like it's
tempting you and you're seeing that
every day constantly constantly you're
like oh
oh yeah i think it works both ways as
well though because as a guy
like back in the day you were just
obviously before social media if you
were just competing with the guys that
went to your school or the guys in your
area and now you're competing with
people from america that have yachts
people who have
planes
like and you're just here like
i'm making off but like oh i ain't got
new york do you know what no you go you
go first the amount of girls i know so
like that aren't that aren't the
the greatest looking in the world like
just normal yeah that have
a bunch of blue tick guys i'm talking
i'm not going to bait out teams but a
lot of fun
i've gone through the request wow
literally so a lot of people have a
question i have a question is it because
she
while she looks
average in real life on her instagram
it's so edited she looks above average
yeah instagrams are like not like so
edited just she reveals
she she's like a good body catfish
catfish nah she's a decent body but
she's not wearing a lot yeah yeah so
it's kind of screaming like easy
don't know what you're talking about
there's a thin line as well between that
subject i think some people they feel
like they think like some women they
show too much it's because they want
they are weak and they are insecure and
they are trying to
you know
call some attention
but i don't think so like some people
maybe some other people not i think it's
all about who you are in the end of the
day because sometimes i met a few people
they look so wow on instagram and then
you meet them and they are very humble
they are very confident like confident
you know and they are not at all what
you think yeah but i i think that
if you're posting your body on instagram
it's a hundred percent for attention
like there is nothing else that it is
for yep you want you want validation for
your body i'm not
i'm not above it
i understand where you're coming from
and half of it is 100 that right i think
also when you're like um happy with
something or proud of it like proud of
the work have you done like the progress
you made yeah you do but absolutely for
people to see it or else it would have
been staying in your camera i agree yeah
but i think also to show that you're
like proud of it yeah
so
so other question when
on social media
what do you guys consider cheating i'm
going to give you a couple examples
this is fun so guys liking instagram
models bikini pictures
i mean that's not cheating
it's not cheating but it's like why was
that necessary
but if you it's not cheating
but it's just kind of moist
why are you doing it bro but if you saw
like a male
would you no because i was like why
would i do it but i understand cheating
you
i didn't think um
it's okay for the guys out there that do
that like why yeah exactly
she doesn't see exactly yeah on the
guy's part it's just thirsty and it's
it's a bit moist yeah
it's a bit moist like you shouldn't yeah
there's no point in doing that just look
let's go that's it yeah yeah i think we
all have eyes and we appreciate
beautiful things it's human so if i see
a guy that is pretty and he looks good
and he looks hot even on the street i
mean i'm not gonna be like like on him
if i see on instagram why not you know
like even if you're in a relationship
yeah i feel like at least i can see if
my partner is confident and if you trust
me because i think there's a trouble on
that that i will say okay my partner
doesn't trust me and my partner is
insecure and i'm i'm not up to that
you know i think everyone has
insecurities but you should not um i how
do you say mirror
those insecurities and others wait who'd
you say that again so what makes them
insecure
like me liking someone who's
not liking how would you say me thinking
that someone is beautiful it's okay to
see right she's beautiful right he's
beautiful yeah but that's something else
though that's something completely else
that's just appreciating that people are
like yeah but i think there's a
difference between looking at someone
and interacting with it i think because
that's sending them a message exactly
it's the message you're sending no no
but i like like i think
it's like baby steps you know what i
mean like it starts it starts it's
patient for him to like because most of
the time nowadays i feel like especially
girls on instagram their way of shooting
their shot is they just like one or two
of your photos boys as well men as well
some guys will follow the girl if you're
like if you're like if you're about that
life you just lack a few and just see
what happens in it but here's the thing
because usually nine times out of ten
the man is pursuing
the like if if a guy likes a girl's
photo
she's
most the time she's not gonna then jump
in his dm's most of the time hanzo might
like it back and wait for him to do it
if the girl likes a guy's picture that's
that's an invitation yeah that's that's
a golden ticket slide in please
yeah yeah so
yeah
so the guys so girls yeah they'll like
two or three photos and that's when you
know that's when you slide in yeah
that's when you know that's when you
know that's like this especially if
you've just post a photo and you they've
just liked it that's nothing but if you
haven't posted anything in a couple
weeks they've gone on your page they've
gone through your photos
like it might not even be the most
recent free it might be they've scrolled
through liked a couple photos what if
what if they because that's the new
thing like liking instagram stories do
you guys think that's also an invitation
just like the instagram story
if you like the instagram story that's
demon times
[Music]
because sometimes you might click on you
might click on a photo you might look
through the likes see who are who's
liked it as one of my boys liked it but
stories you can't do that so so yeah
so
so what okay so what about swiping up on
someone's story yeah is that cheating is
that okay okay
is that cheating but you know the person
if you know the point but as in does he
swipe up and he's like oh have a good
workout or is it okay let's say let's
say you you have um an acquaintance that
both of both of you know okay the guy
you and the guy right
and he swipes up on our stories how do
you know if it like is it ever friendly
no is it always known
it is flirty what about guys what do you
think
so can you we're gonna repeat that okay
so say say um
okay say say me and you are dating right
okay and you and i'm your mutual oh yeah
we're the mutual friend you always are
swiping up on her story
but like we both try to call right
is it ever friendly
if i'm always doing it there's there's
an under there's probably an underlying
exactly yeah
like i said if he's just like oh do you
know when or was the movie good was this
good like what that's that's fine
but like reacting all the time
where she looks fire yeah
my god
yeah
how do you think
social media
has influenced women's standards
and men's oh a lot i think social media
in general just change relationships
because you're seeing all these
instagram models and it's not real like
nothing's real really
and so
that's their like you're at home with
your girl or your man or whatever you're
seeing all these models on that and
they're like they might be liking your
stuff dmnu and stuff so it's just like
oh i could get that but then
when you meet him in real life it's not
the same so that's that the standards
have just
risen and it's so sad because it creates
a competition between the partners and
there should be no competition
but it should be like
it's like violent valentine's day people
post process stuff oh i've got this
massive teddy i've got all these
chocolates like
and sometimes it's fake it's not easy
yeah you just put you're just doing it
to prove oh my boyfriend likes me more
than your boyfriend likes you or
whatever it's like a competition it's
true if you really love it it's like an
ego thing
yeah yes
there we go thanks